samedi 10 novembre 2018 sera désormais
la date anniversaire de la première
grève du tcsp
c'est le réseau fort de france la menthe
a surpris ils le seront par cette
annonce alors que ses usagers patienter
tranquillement à cet arrêt de
chateauboeuf depuis quelques minutes
il savait bien il savait très bien qu'il
y aura eu ce débrayage je pense pourquoi
ils ne voient pas avertis au moins la
veille moi je lui dis je suis vient la
métropole betty c'est bien il ya enfin
des transports en commun qui fonctionne
bien en martinique
donc je vais aller sûrement louer une
voiture bon quand on nous parle de
pollution de développement durable je
trouve ça dommage
le licenciement d'une salariée pour
faute grave serait à l'origine de ce
débrayage
certains collègues la femme licenciée
estime que cette sanction est abusive
je conteste ce ce qui m'est reproché
parce que j'ai porté tous les éléments
disant que ce qui m'est reproché et haut
du cadre légal
malgré ça la direction et assistent je
leur ai montré je leur ai donné des
documents et il persiste pour injures on
veut la licence et donc soutien parce
que c'est par ces ballons mal et après
on voit à voir avec la direction si
l'idée c'est de 2
d'arranger les choses quoi en fin de
matinée responsable du personnel
représentant du syndicat majoritaire et
l'employé concerné par le licenciement
entre négociations à l'issue de cet
entretien
aucune avancée les deux parties campent
sur leur position au terme de cette
réunion nous n'avons pas réussi à nous
entendre
quant à ce licenciement qui a été
prononcé un pur je le rappelle faute
grave
et donc
le syndicat maintient sa position de
soutien aux salariés concernés et donc
nous allons sans doute avoir encore des
négociations des discussions et
peut-être voire même
d'autres lieux où débattre de cette
question et donc la population doit
savoir que nous sommes dans une
situation de blocage pour le moment si
la direction de la santé annonce
cependant qu'elle reste favorable au
dialogue
les membres du syndicat majoritaire
engage le bras de fer ils parlent eux de
préavis de grève